everyone the lbcv launched a new  campaign this week they are talking  about having the full vegas experience  while staying safe  [Music]  [Applause]  keep your mask up  [Music]  let your hair down that's one of two ads  that launched on monday  the airplane across the country and  online as well the lbcba says people are  feeling more safe about traveling now  and numbers have been going up the past  month what we want people to know is  i mentioned hair we want people know  they can come here  unwind safely let their hair down but  keep your mask up because that's  important during covid  we also want people to know that they  can come to las vegas any day of the  week not just the weekend  yeah every day is the weekend here he  says tsa numbers show vegas is among the  top destinations  most tourists are still coming in though  from arizona california and  utah john yeah we saw those long drives  back to l.a on  sunday or monday i guess it was